this video is sponsored by mubi mubi is
an online curated cinema get your free
trial today
at moobie.com thomasflight
[Applause]
as vfx tech makes stitching multiple
shots together much easier
long takes or at least sequences that
have the appearance of being a long take
are gaining in popularity whether it's
entire films shot using this technique
like birdman or 1917
or just the longer sequences found in
spectre the revenant
mission and possible fallout and others
the boundaries of what's possible with
this technique are being pushed
to new levels netflix's new chris
hemsworth action flick extraction
is yet another film that pushes the
boundaries of what's possible with these
kinds of sequences
midway through the film there's an
absolutely insane 12-minute sequence
it starts here
proceeds to a car chase
moves into buildings
jumps across buildings
falls out of buildings into the street
and continues into another car chase
all without a visible cut but what makes
this technique
a gimmick and what makes it a serious
tool
for filmmakers to use to tell their
stories
why use a long take or the illusion of
one why do something that is
theoretically more difficult and
complicated
and that doesn't give you flexibility in
the editing room there are two ways to
understand the potential benefit
of a long take in film sometimes long
takes are used
to enhance the realism of the scene
cuts can be used to obscure weak
choreography or
swap between stunt actors and regular
actors when you don't cut
there's nowhere for performers to hide
sometimes though
not cutting is more of a formless choice
the long take isn't being used to make
things more realistic
but in concert with other aspects of
filmmaking to generate
a feeling emotion or effect that helps
tell the story
the famous steadicam shot that snakes
its way through a restaurant and
goodfellas
isn't done to make the scene feel more
realistic but to invoke the feeling of
importance and grandiosity that the
characters
feel let's take a closer look at these
two approaches and where extraction
fits into this the explanation for why
not cutting enhances realism
is usually this the viewer
subconsciously perceives a cut as
artifice
even if it doesn't register consciously
on some level a cut
breaks immersion by not cutting things
we get the sense that what's happening
is more real and less manipulated by the
filmmakers
this idea holds some truth but if
realism is your goal you have to balance
not cutting against other things that
also break immersion
and create a sense of artifice and i
think to a certain extent the idea that
editing inherently breaks immersion is a
little bit flawed
here's an example one of my favorite
long takes is this one from children of
men
it's about the same length as the one
from extraction it's incredibly tense
and complex
as each additional minute passes without
a cut you become more tense and immersed
in the scene
recently i was watching this film with
my brothers while we were watching it we
got about halfway through the scene and
one of them said
is this still the same shot it took
about four or five minutes for them to
realize
there were no cuts but that's good when
realism is the goal you don't want to
notice
the technique but the shot ends here
and the scene returns to a normal
pattern of editing
a few minutes and a bunch of cuts later
the same brother said
wait have they still not cut my brother
was so immersed in the scene that
he didn't notice when the cuts resumed
in other words the return of editing
didn't suddenly break his immersion
when we are immersed in a film that's
well edited our minds are seeing the
images as a continuous stream
regardless of whether there's editing
only human
the shot from steve mcqueen's hunger
holds for an incredible 17 minutes
business of the soul it's a stunning
shot and the lack of editing causes you
to hang on every word and every silence
but when mcqueen does finally decide to
cut you're not suddenly snapped out of
the moment
you've been in the great door and done
it all
right
the eventual edit advances the emotion
of the scene
it doesn't break it
so let's return to the scene from
extraction
does this scene build tension and
immersion by enhancing realism
i think the answer is somewhat this is
obviously subjective because immersion
is a subjective experience but
it's still worth talking about and
trying to identify why something might
be
more or less immersive for a majority of
viewers
there are many moments during the scene
where the lack of editing
is very effective it builds tension and
suspense
and heightens the realism of the scene
these moments of action are compelling
exciting and interesting to watch
but the transitions between these larger
portions of action
are where things start to get a little
questionable for me some of these
transitions between shots are obviously
fake or physically impossible
and sometimes the position and
composition of the camera only makes
sense
because they needed a place to hide the
cut
these things break immersion and create
a sense of artifice for me
as much as or sometimes more than a cut
would
one of the benefits of a cut is that
while it might on some level create a
subtle sense of artifice
audiences are so used to seeing cuts
that they're much more blind to a cut
than they are other kinds of trickery
this is where the benefit of the real
long take becomes clear
when using a long take for realism this
long shot from children of men
is a genuine long take and i think it
fits well within the realist
style of the film the entire two and a
half hour film victoria
is truly a single take that's so stuck
hey
i have to go guys where you going where
you going
i there are differences between these
long takes
and the ones we see in extraction and
1917 when it comes to realism
for one thing in true long takes there
are no noticeable
digital transitions or physically
impossible camera movements
the movement of the camera feels real
because
it is but the other benefit of a true
long take
is that i think it gives the
performances an energy
that we can pick up on subconsciously in
victoria there's a tension that rises as
the film goes on
not just because there are no cuts but
because the performers
literally can't make a mistake
there are real stakes in the production
just like there are stakes in the film
and i think we can perceive that in
what's on screen for scenes that are
artificially stitched we lose the real
tension that adds to the on-screen
tension
i think there's a potential for
artificial long takes to have the same
effect as true long takes when it comes
to realism
but i think until vfx stitching is good
enough to be truly invisible
filmmakers should be very careful of how
they use this technique
[Applause]
but completely invisible filmmaking and
total immersion aren't always
the goal maybe for extraction realism
wasn't the motivation behind
doing a long take but if the motivation
for using this technique and extraction
isn't realism we have to ask what the
motivation
is for a film like birdman the purpose
of the continuous take
is not to build tension and enhance
realism but actually to stylistically
elevate the film beyond reality
it's used because it's unrealistic for
birdman the surreal nature of the style
fits the surreal nature of the story
season three of mr robot features an
entire episode that takes place
as a single take but the technique is
used to enhance a strange feeling that
elliott the main character is having
something isn't right like something
slipped away from me
what is it i can't put my finger on it
what am i even doing here and within a
show that frequently
breaks the fourth wall help me figure
this out
do not leave me stay focused
a filmmaking technique that draws
attention to itself doesn't harm the
story
i think the big problem the sequence
from extraction runs into
is that it awkwardly sits between these
two approaches
is the camera a documentary style camera
that has to jump
from building to building and shakes as
if it's being handled by a person
or is it a disembodied orb that can
float through glass
and in front of cars if the goal is
realism moments like this seem to run
counter to that goal
for extraction if this is just being
done as a stylistic choice does it fit
within the film as a whole and is it
motivated by the scene
i think it's particularly telling that
in other scenes the filmmakers use
a well-executed but fairly generic fast
cutting style with handheld camera work
this long scene isn't part of a larger
commitment to
longer takes in general within the film
it just kind of sits on its own
the smaller sections of uncut action
within this longer scene
are great they're impressive well
choreographed
moments like this one definitely benefit
from the lack of editing
but what is really gained by not cutting
between these larger sections like
here here or here
aside from the ability to say hey we
have this 12-minute one-take sequence
i'm not saying you couldn't mix
formalist and realistic approaches to a
long take together
but in this scene switching between the
two doesn't seem motivated by
story or emotion it just seems done
purely to maintain the effect
i'm not going to say filmmakers should
never just show off for fun
but if you're gonna do something
bombastic and showy
just for the fun of it it might work
better within a film that has a more fun
bombastic style
or story overall the goal of this video
is seriously not to dunk on extraction
and the hard work that was put into this
sequence
if anything this is the most interesting
part of the film
and i like that filmmakers are
experimenting with what's possible
with artificial long takes but i think
as they do
it's valuable to discuss what works and
what
doesn't i think extraction's use of this
technique
showcases both how this technique can be
used effectively
and how it can go wrong and i'm more
concerned with the attitude this trend
creates towards editing it's not editing
itself that inherently pulls you out of
the story
it's bad editing every cut and
composition needs to be
intentional and choosing when not to cut
is just
as much of an editing decision as
choosing when to cut and like every cut
every decision not to cut should be done
in service of the story whether you're
trying to enhance realism
or create a certain effect or emotion
not just
to use a certain technique for the sake
of doing it
hollywood directors who use long takes
tend to get all the buzz but
a lot of the most interesting longer
takes i've seen in cinema come from
international classic or independent
film it's one of the reasons if you're
interested in filmmaking you need to
explore
more than just what's in hollywood and
if you're interested in doing that a
great
place to find stuff outside the
hollywood bubble
is mubi when you sign up for your
extended 30 day free trial you'll get
access to a new
film every day you can go to movie.com
thomasflight to sign up for your
extended free trial that's mubi.com
thomasflight for your free trial thanks
again to mubi for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching i want to
thank my patreon supporters
if you're interested in supporting my
channel via patreon you can go to
patreon.com
thomasflight i do a podcast and bonus
videos that you can get depending on the
level
of your support